taux espagnols sont saturés les hôtels
de leçons donc décidé de venir en aide
aux personnels soignants c'est le cas à
barcelone un barcelone un établissement
accueille gratuitement les malades en
phase de guérison mais aussi les
soignants qui préfère ne pas rentrer
chez eux
image d'aurélie chamerois récit d'emilie
google ce ne sont plus des clients qui
accueille cet hôtel 5 étoiles depuis
plus d'une semaine le melia sarria a
ouvert ses portes aux patients en phase
de guérison
il s'agit de soulager les établissements
hospitaliers saturés en raison du grand
nombre de personnes contaminées dans le
pays
321 une chambre sont disponibles dont
305 sont réservés aux personnes
atteintes du coronavirus ces personnes
ont un profil assez autonomes mais à la
maison elles ne peuvent observer
correctement le confinement
elles doivent donc rester ici durant les
quatorze jours qui suivent leur sortie
de l'hôpital
tout un étage a été affecté aux
soignants il séjourne ceux qui préfèrent
ne pas regagner leur domicile de peur de
contaminer leurs proches une
cinquantaine d'entre eux travaillent sur
place à l'hôtel où ils continuent à
s'occuper des patients pour le directeur
du méliès arias l'important est que tous
s'y sentent bien
nous trouvons un motivation quotidienne
grâce aux passions ils sont très
reconnaissants nous offrons un accueil
très particulier chaleureux à chacun
d'entre nous leur donnons toute notre
affection et notre hospitalité
l'hôtel ne facture pas l'occupation de
ces chambres
quant à la compagnie nationale
d'électricité endesa elle a également
fait un geste
l'hôtel ne lui devra rien durant cette
période où il rend service à la
collectivité fermés en raison de la
crise sanitaire en espagne d'autres
hôtels se sont transformées en hôpitaux
notamment à madrid qui fait figure de
centre de la contamination dans le pays